[Musique]
ernie via massillon bonjour vous nous
venaient d'haïti alors vous êtes
précisément mairesse assesseurs de la
commune de môle saint nicolas mais reste
assesseurs c'est l'équivalent de
maire-adjoint de chez nous voilà alors
vous êtes en martinique dans le cadre
d'une visite de travail en coopération
régionale décentralisée avec 4 nord la
communauté d'agglomération du pays nord
de la martinique alors la rencontre
officielle aura lieu demain toute la
journée sur le terrain pour vous et
votre délégation dans trois communes au
carbet au prêcheur et à saint pierre
voilà alors l'intercommunalité les
agglomérations de communes on voit que
ça existe en haïti puisque votre vous
faites partie la commune de môle saint
nicolas fait partie de la mam
l'association des municipalités de
l'arrondissement du môle saint nicolas
qui regroupe en tout quatre communes
alors en plus du môle saint nicolas il y
à la commune de jean ravel lombardo
police mais les bébés de haine
l'intercommunalité les agglomérations
commune est ce que ça fonctionne bien en
haïti ah oui pour une haïti et
connaissant la situation et des communes
alors la situation et devinez l'habilité
des communes allez dans le bateau s
les quatre communes et dont vous venez
de citer à savoir le monde saint nicolas
a bel et bon margolis et bdl et ses
communes en en justement y voient la
nécessité de se mettre à
l'intercommunalité pour pouvoir répondre
aux problèmes et aux problèmes qui sont
qui sont communs alors et alors je suis
je suis appel à l'or et aux élections et
de 2015 est alors évoluer d'autres lui
faire cesser ces c'est mon premier
mandat comme comme mairesse adjointe et
de ses petites communes alors les
appréciations qui se sont passées on
voit la nécessité est de mettre sur
place
l'intercommunalité juste vous posez et
les problèmes communs de et ceux de 2,2
de l'arrondissement de saint nicolas et
dont je suis et mairesses et c'est le
chef lieu de l'arrondissement et d'être
athée il ya des représentants des trois
autres communes qui sont venus avec vous
avant dans cette situation alors la
délégation et se compose de deux de
l'accompagnateur et l'adema à des masses
et c est ensemble on aimait mieux en
haïti c'est une ong qui est donne des
assistances et techniques et mêmes
financiers aux communautés oui parce que
cap nord nous dit on il ya massillon que
les élus du bas nord-ouest d'haïti sont
venus pour analyser et s'inspirer de
l'expérience jusqu'à intercommunal de
cap nord et de la cacem qui est aussi
partenaire une coopération schéma cesser
une visite des ddd change et dix ans de
partage et pouvoir mieux et organiser
notre intercommunalité et juste pour
pouvoir et d'allemand et partager avec
eux et avec les nounous avec la
martinique est ce que nous au niveau de
l'arrondissement du musée nicholas nous
avons comme potentialités et aussi et le
dans des caisses que nous pouvons aussi
apporté à ramener à la maison
alors on va on va y venir mais donc
l'intercommunalité d'après ce qu'on
croit comprendre c'est quelque chose qui
est assez
nouveau récents en haïti où ça fait
longtemps que dans l'intercommunalité
alors que je veux dire est ce qu'il ya
des freins encore à ce que ça fonctionne
encore mieux
alors justement alors vous savez qu'en
haïti et stabilité politique et sa sale
état d' un peu et les activités les deux
là
la première structure de notre réalité
c'était et est depuis 2006 début 2006
lors de la négociation et et de l'accès
au président joseph michel martelly
sané ne fonctionnait pas avec les les
moyens qu'il alonso les mains et énumère
les élections et nous on ne s'organise
et pas et maintenant avec et et d'autres
administrations de 2015 et nous nous
nous sommes en train d'errer là c'est
dur et là c est la structure des
intérimaires un thé alors il y a dix
thématiques qui ont été retenues 1 par
cap nord pour cette action de
coopération avec l'association des
municipalités de l'arrondissement du
môle saint nicolas duban nord-ouest
d'haïti
alors on va pas les citer toutes un mais
par exemple il ya agriculture pêche
culture tourisme environnement ou encore
éducation et santé
alors pour vous dans le cas de duba
nord-ouest d'haïti
quelles sont les thématiques
prioritaires en sachant que dans cette
région et notamment dans la commune donc
de môle saint nicolas il ya beaucoup de
l'agriculture et de pêche
mais vous voulez aussi développer le
tourisme et tourisme h 20 alors moi je
vais y avait priorisé maîtrise des
tourismes et il y a alors d'histoire
même et du mousseux nicolas il ya
beaucoup de sites touristiques et à
beaucoup de 2,2
deux forts et si on arrive avec ford et
ancien forain des anciens châteaux forts
à mettre en valeur et c'est ces sites
touristiques et a aussi et il ya aussi
le pelage résigné ça c'est vraiment et
c'est vraiment exceptionnel
alors on a l'habitude de dire c'est
c'est le paradis du nord s le plaisir
d'accord donc vous prioriser le tourisme
et la pêche
et oui parce que le maulvi à 60% de
alors au jeu kg précisé je crois qu'il
ya plus d'un peu plus de 30000 habitants
le mot le môle saint nicolas c'est ça à
peu près oui oui aaa
il habite le dernier et 2015 ça passe à
'aa' plus de oui carrément
ah oui donc vous avez eu une une
croissance de la population parce que
c'est vrai qu'en vers 2009 on était à 30
mille et quelques temps mais alors donc
je disais le maulvi à 60% de la pêche
15% d'élevage caprin à peu près et puis
donc l'agriculture en 500 notamment la
culture de la pistache du maïs du mail
haricots alors qu'est ce que vous vous
pouvez amener comme justement comme
expérience comme par rapport à ça
notamment agriculture et pêche peut-être
pour nous nos communes du nord de la
martinique et non non non non alors quoi
la pêche la pêche c'est et c'est
vraiment et c'est vraiment
extraordinaire et à expérimenter et où
12 à partager avec avec la martinique et
en agriculture et nous avons et les
céréales comme vous qu'on me le dire
là est la ricoh l'épissage ya aussi le
russe est le leaf est et et leurs chiens
ont fait de lui la ruelle de risque
justement justement cccc c'est vraiment
très recherché est partout et il ya
aussi des
le vivre de la banane de la patate ou
aussi j'ai passé ce serait et est très
très important dé créer une comédienne à
une coopération une synergie entre jeu
semestre
la martinique j'espère que et nous
aurons beaucoup à faire ensemble
alors pour conclure cet entretien et en
il ya massillon mairesse assesseurs de
la commune de môle saint nicolas en
haïti justement parlons un peu de la
situation actuelle global général
radigois vous faites un peu là vous
réagissez
mais vous avez un jeune président de la
république je venais le moïse âgé de 50
ans qui est issu du milieu des affaires
c'était avant le président il était chef
d'entreprise pdg justement d'une
entreprise de production et
d'exportation de bananes
comment ça se passe en ce moment
l'actualité c'est petro caribe les fonds
l'argent qui a été livrée avec petro
caribe j'ai justement à incidentielle
petro caribe et j'ai c'est qu'il y à une
enquête
alors là la corruption les détournements
autour de petro caribe ce pétrole qui
arrivait à bas prix dans certains pays
de la caraïbe dont haïti
je sais qu'il ya une enquête en cours et
la population il demande d'aidé
reddition de comptes
ah oui oui à des manifestations ce monde
avait des des manifestations massives et
je suis que le gouvernement aura à
prades les mesures qui s'imposent et
d'ailleurs hier jouvenel moïse a renvoyé
deux proches collaborateurs
selon son premier mini son nouveau
premier ministre jean henry céant
c'est une manière de débarrasser son
environnement à lui je venais le moïse
des personnes impliquées dans le dossier
de corruption qui galvanise la colère
populaire en haïti
justement je pense que ce sens dès lors
les signaux des signaux merci à rené
bien massillon d'être venu bon secours
des travailleurs marché à moi de vous
remercier